all right welcome to another edition of
a beginner breakdown I'm your host Mike
Hammer last night Jonathan fronts hosted
his chess openings explain class and
after the class that was pure mayhem we
had three games that all started
efore d5 pawn takes Queen takes Knight
c3 so this was the starting position
okay so we'll see how those games pan
out but before that we have a very
interesting game from Late Night with
David Letterman where he had the current
rural champion at the time Garry
Kasparov on his program and this game
ensued
Letterman had the black pieces okay so
so this is the position on the board and
David Letterman of course loves to give
check especially when it's to the world
champion so he plays check and so so you
know he gets out of the check with
Bishop to e2 so after the game was
played Letterman said to a Kasparov like
when did you know you had me and he was
like when you played the dubious Queen
to e6 check so so just cuz you know you
play a check it could turn out to be the
losing move okay so you know David
Letterman precedes 96 so he's
threatening the big pawn 45 but let him
is too good for that so he moves his
Queen and so so now so now a champion
he's tempting Letterman like and
Letterman can't resist you know free
pawn okay and so the rook is under
attack so rook attacks the Queen there's
only one spot for the Queen to go
Oh Letterman I mean he sees his pieces
of tax the way moves you know it's more
than I could say about some people you
know so so that's pretty good so now
once again nutterman's attack so here
move it but the night there isn't very
good I mean where can this night even go
anywhere I mean be for looks like it
just winds up a night out right but yeah
he's got played better night b5
obviously better than before because
instead of winning night we're gonna go
to win the rock okay so let's see if
Letterman can figure out any way to do
this alright he does does anybody have
any suggestions how to stop night take
c7 check yep yep plain just like David
Letterman okay and so now now I get two
guys on the c-pawn so big trouble big
trouble for Letterman here so he's gonna
he's gonna lose a lot of material pretty
quick so night takes check King moves
Knight attacks the Queen
so Letterman's like oh man look at this
free night oh not so so obviously Knight
takes pawn Chuck King moves see your
queen let me say alright I'll get
another night but then boom another
night is hanging so now you know it's
only our program so you know you got to
just get with the Kasparov alright it's
fun you got his Queen but now let's get
the King already alright so here we go
are we get the Queen out there the Queen
and the rook that's who's got to do the
checkmating I mean knights and bishops
cool for winning material but they're
gonna mop up the mess here okay so
alright you can the rook involved here
alright so rook pin
the pawn rook moves and you're gonna be
shocked here you're gonna be shocked
ready to be shocked
alright pawn moves not too much of a
shocker b6 now are we ready to be
shocked this is through so fast okay so
pinch up moves
fish up Queen moves now Bishop back now
he's ready to give them the shocker the
shock are we ready to be shocked all
right all right are we ready to B now
we're ready to be shocked all right
can anybody so this pawn is in a pin
right the G file is protected by this
guy you got to be world champion garry
kasparov to see this one all right you
want be like garry kasparov and see a
shocking move for the win or do you just
want to play all by yourself
you get doing yeah all right not quite I
mean it's probably good but garry
kasparov move is just excellent so
notice the bishop and the Queen all in
this big diagonal and notice if for some
reason this Jeep on just would go away
where are you doing what move could you
have Queen takes Knight Chuck let's see
if it's shocking up so there's only one
way for him to take it the King can't
capture protected pieces pawn can't take
because of the rook so he has to take
well he doesn't have to take if he if he
wants to take he has to take back like
this and then where's what's the winning
move
checkmate excellent okay so let's say he
goes oh I just retreat now maybe you
want to get that rook involved rook
takes pawn check and then now he's only
has one legal move take and then it's
over
checkmate yeah that's officially
checkmate let's make sure the other one
was tough because computer than the
computer in it like shout it out
all right now he sees all right all
right checkmate
all right so that's how Gary Kasparov
played against David Letterman but as
you'll see when a staff plays as the
black pieces we do pretty well here and
now I played on everybody's favorite
Mario Roper all right so guys you see my
big improvement Queen to e5 Chuck
instead of Queen to e6 there is also the
Patzer variation based on the joke
Patzer sees a Czech Patzer plays a check
okay so he moves this Bishop and now we
attack the pin pieces so does everybody
know which move I'm really hoping Mario
makes here well yeah I mean I wouldn't
be upset if he did but I really want to
play Knight f3 because then I could just
take it and he has to take back with
this pawn giving himself double pawns
double isolated pawns and an isolated
pawns and it won't want to be castling
over there but Mario is just too smart
he plays a rook to be one all right
probably d4 is good but all right we're
work to be why he's gonna bring us
Bishop out here but but I want to just
get my guy going here so keep attacking
the pin pieces and so now if when I
Castle Mario thinks he finds a trick
it's like your night bishop night night
queen it's like it's in a pen so I'm
gonna move their threatening check and
and all the good stuff alright so now I
got a tactic alright so who is defending
this knight the bishop so we can do that
little remove the defender no because
the same piece that I would take with is
doing the pinning yeah yeah if Knight
takes Knight he'll see your queen and if
I take with the guy
well I could take that and then we could
do all this let's see what the computer
says yeah that computer loves that yep
they computer loves that maybe I should
have played that how do I win a piece
out of that oh man so I could play so if
I play Knight takes Knight
what happened oh so I want to play Queen
takes b5 and then if he but then he'll
be like I'm not taking I'm not taking
your queen I'm gonna take this with Shaq
all right and then the but well maybe
I'll play off five now let's see what
the computer says all right this is the
moment of truth yeah it gives white the
advantage okay so we have to look and
depth all the lines here but anyhow I
see it forced window well it's not even
forced but so after night there I take
here he should play the intermezzo
Knight takes pawn Chuck but instead he
takes and now I have so I gotta take
this knife back but before I take the
knight back what move can I sneak in
here
they take c2 Chuck okay yes so so just
in case you're tuning in the first three
moves our program because we're going
after Jonathan trans today's lecture we
have an exhibition match game 45 with
five second delay match with where the
moves are forced before d5 pawn takes
Queen takes Knight c3 yeah or else I
probably wouldn't play this very often
alright so now he plays rook to c1
innocent-looking move right wrong do you
went you know what White's threatening
here checkmate yeah uh-oh checkmate
so let's stop it
and now he's like okay if you're not
gonna let me have checkmate I'm gonna
block it off like a it's like okay
Murray or whatever now I offer him a
chance to have double pawns but instead
he's gonna attack my queen so I'm like
okay I'm not gonna let you have double
points I'm gonna attack the pawn so he
blocks it with the night and so now I
tried to attack the knight and now you
decide to trade Queens I ask him after
the game why he decided he said because
he was afraid so
that's my hope are you so now II 6
attacks the night so he's like alright
I'll give you double pawns whatever and
Knight moves
now I decide I'm gonna play good and I
bring my bishop out attacked the pawn
and stopped his pawns from marching down
so he's got to stop this Oh
he plays rook the seat to Brooke the d3
exclamation mark attacks the pawn Oh
King to e2 attacks my rook
so I defend it and double my rooks
forcing the rook to defend and now I can
take his pawn for free so rook attacks
the bishop instead I decided hey I'm
gonna attack the pawn all right forcing
the knight to go back to f1 now I'm like
okay a5 so now after rook to a4 I can
simply defend the pawn with rook to d5
okay Axl all right there's no reason to
give him a past H point okay all right
so now Mario comes up with the plan of
the century okay f4 you really want to
pay attention for this one all right so
rook attacks the pawn so he decides all
right
f5 all right so he's playing some ad
hope chest he's thinking wow I cannot
resist getting triple pawns and but I
decided nope I'll take
and now Mario's back to square one
without a sapling
so he's you know I'll tack your rook
it's like I'll pin your knight get out
of the pin I'll take your pawn
so now Mario's he's going to work here
look at that move men threading a lot of
stuff huh threaten my rook threads check
I don't even know what to do so when
you're in desperate times Chuck right
you check it at least now now I got
everybody going for the big pin here all
right so I'm desperate again right so
there's two things I could do I could
check or I could pin the night which I
think I pinned the night so he gets out
of the pin and now I'm like okay I'm
just going to take hoping that he takes
back with the King okay so but instead
Mario sees that King takes is a is a
blunder because of you know Bishop
Bishop check you know winning the rook
so so he plays rook takes e4 alright so
I give him a check King up so just
because I've lost in exchange who would
you like to play here white or black
black because I got a lot of pawns one
two three four five six seven and he's
only got three so I'm still winning by
the piece count so I move my king up he
attacks my pawn is there any way I can
save it
nope so so I might as well just give him
up no I know he's gonna take my pawn and
then go here but do you think I really
want my king passive for this entire
endgame No so I'm just gonna let him
have that pawn - because he's doubled
weak and he's pretty much a non-factor
anyway so I'd rather have an active King
and some lazy pulling on the f7 so Chuck
start advancing those pawns the only way
I'm gonna win this game is if I get a
queen
yes wait what king d3i
check him again and then if he moves up
well if he moves here yeah
all right b5 this is the game so I
pushed my pawn and you know he's just
gonna get that pawn so that's not the
end of the world but I don't want him to
get this point as well or also get two
passers the h and the G so I play f5 so
when he checks me okay it's not the end
of the world
so now Bari who does the right thing
he's like you know five moves away from
getting a queen let's do it so now I got
to be quick so so I'm gonna try to stop
him with my rook all right so Rick here
attacks the pawn so King there so now
rook attacks
so now Mario's got two decisions well
he's got three decisions I guess all
right so he can protect with a pawn he
can get behind the pass pawn or he can
make through the dumb rook where he gets
in front of the pawn so which one you
think Mario chooses yeah he takes the
dumb work scenario so the dumb rook is
not very good because in the end
and now oh my Rick can't move that's the
sad um rook okay and now you can never
promote that point you're hoping that
that I play a silly move like this like
this and then I can then he can deliver
the check and then we'll make King moves
I get a queen but when you have a
situation like that just don't allow
your King to be checked by the dumb rook
and you'll be living large okay all
right so of course Mario goes for the
dumb rule and so now I get my guy going
now Mario makes a big mistake plays d4
and now my bishop becomes a monster
okay he's defending the queening square
attacking the pawn he's just and look
and now he's on the same diagonal as as
the HR pawn so life is good so rook
takes I would love that the trade rooks
here I said he attacked my bishop and I
just say a - I'll just go for it
so rook goes you know I can get a queen
now there's no reason not to and now I
can go and win this pawn you guys me a
check it gives me another check I don't
care attacks this pawn there's no way I
can save it I do not want to play a move
like rook to e4 and that's just
humiliating huh
right humiliating so be careful don't be
like oh you know I've got four pawns in
an endgame let's trade rooks okay you
got it
gotta smash this compensation here so
trading is fine because it's gonna be
really tough for him to stop this stuff
right all right so he thinks he's got a
big pin going but what's an easy way to
get out of this check yeah excellent
and then you can check them again and I
thought about just playing c3 and being
funny but I'm like it now
check check
and well one more check just for fun and
then it's over
right there's no way he can he can stop
me
I got mate in about eight year mate in
eight yep that's great
alright so now we can see see how the
host Jonathan Krantz does he has he
actually has the black pieces again we
all have to the black pieces oh all
right so so obviously it's gonna start
out their Scandinavian in this position
I said he decides not to check he
decides to go to a five and now white
can't resist a check it's like you're
not gonna check me I'm gonna check you
who thinks that this is a good check for
a white do we have anybody no because
you can just black with the C pawn and
that's actually where the Queen loves to
be on this diagonal back to get to c7
and a lot of scenarios blacks queen is
gonna get the c7 anyway so you just gave
black a free temple so alright so he
plays Bishop back to c4 Knight up gets
his night out bishop pins the night
white gets castle
ye6 bishop breaks the pin so bishop
moves a ch3 is played magnus carlsen and
the Blitz game kind of similar to this
takes the knight but all right Jonathan
decides I'm gonna retreat so Queen to e1
is played
who would much rather be on a 1 here the
rook the Queen just never really belongs
on a 1 it gets his night out he's three
all right so Jonathan's gonna go for it
all right he's like this King is pretty
safe because there's a knight
Bishop pawn Knight pawn all protecting
this King even though he's on the same
file as the Queen it's really tough for
him to break through here so then brings
his knight up so Johnson's like well I
get castle anywhere that way all my guys
don't have to just hang around all day
to protect so so yeah if you saw when
the knight moved after castle there was
a discovered attack but Jonathan didn't
mind because look you know it's
protected so Knight attacks the Queen
Jonathan thought for a long time about
going to f5 walking right into the pawn
fork if he plays g4 what move do we have
if the computer didn't already say
excellent and now this Knights hanging
in or anything so that's much better
but here's like alright I'll just play
Queen back to c7 all right so Queen III
another innocent-looking move what is
being attacked
yeah you want that Queen down there on
a7 threatening check no so what move
should you play nope nope King over
right
it's very as we'll see in this game it's
very problematic to be pushing your
pawns in front of your king
so yeah King be a excellent so then
Knight comes up the rook it's over all
right so now look on the G file so now
he plays g4 to stop his opponent from
playing g4 but but this is much better
all right so so it's dangerous so yeah
you could just age five and just break
it open all right
so now he puts the Queen on the same
line so pawn takes what move I mean
obviously white is losing in this
position but I mean he's still okay well
not okay but but you know it's not like
critical here he's now on his deathbed
what move do you think white should play
in this position yeah just you have to
take it back you just have to take it
back all right but instead he gets fancy
here plays Bishop takes no good I think
he was hoping that Jonathan would take
with the Queen and eliminate his
attacker but no sale right and now Queen
h2 I was watching the game live and I
saw the move instantly Jonathan didn't
see it so what what what moves what it
was so if you're playing this game two
moves should just shout at you right
pawn takes check or g3 right g3 is
obviously the best
but Jonathan's like I'm going to play
hope juice I'm gonna hope you don't see
the big night pork which it really
doesn't have to some so Bernard does the
right thing he's just like get get that
night out of here
and so Queen takes and now he's living
for another day
so he's like all right no no pawn takes
but guess what
g3 even has more bike now than it did
previously now that you know the rooks
off the board so Jonathan did okay I
guess so pawn takes Queen the e3 check
King over rook takes so now it's looking
pretty bad for a white his castle is
destroyed you move too many pawns up and
he's in a lot of trouble and now what's
the easiest move in this position yeah
one quick hint the king and the queen or
in the same file yeah Jonathan it's just
not that good he's like I don't want
really really so he's like I'll gonna
attack your Queen then so now he's gonna
maneuver hang up Queen check King mmm
you think Jonathan sees this move he
didn't see it when it was the file
rook g2 yep yep yep yep now you see now
that it's the rank he sees it so Knight
protects the Queen Bishop takes pawn
queen takes Chuck Queen takes rook f3
now I think Jonathan decides it's time
to be funny
after three because if if rook takes
he's gonna get another Queen coming and
nobody can stop him well it's always
like okay I'll protect and now
Jonathan's like I'm a comedian over here
so Queen takes check Knight takes and
now what move do you think he takes the
knight he just pushes and oh oh nobody
can stop the Queen somewhere no I was
like I've had enough no so so the last
game was there was a new guy playing
Danny and there's Jonathan himself the
winner of the last game the best yep and
so so Danny has the black pieces so
obviously what move do you think Danny's
gonna play so we saw Queen b6 check
played by David Letterman Queen a5
played by the lecturer and then we saw
the awesome Queen the e5 check played by
yours truly and remember Danny is a good
player as we may or may not see so what
movie do you think he plays yeah I say
it was mine obviously
give him the check right yeah I'm the
check all right and it plays just like
me
even though his game started before mine
but but he knew he knew what I was gonna
play all right so yeah tax so just
retreat
all right so g4 who thinks that's a good
move anybody nobody
it's a bishop retreats so Knight attacks
the Queen Queen moves Bishop checks so
we saw that in the previous game right
you think that was a good move
no never play the Bishop check if they
can just block with the C pawn right all
right so
it just goes right back home it's like
sorry basically just like you know what
I'm gonna give you a free move c6 and
then another free move right so you just
gave him to free moves it's so very very
devastating but Danny does not put them
to good use I hit the move f6 which is
abysmal and p3 and King up seven so this
is called the wandering King has nothing
to do with the Scandinavian it has
nothing to do with chess but uh we'll
see if so now he should play well
shocked again obviously and I he blacks
it with a six so now yeah g5 just try to
break open the wine drinking night
protects the pawn Knight attacks the
Queen
so Queen to d5 and I said Danny was a
good player home but if you're raiding
rice okay so does anybody like that move
no no no so just if they're gonna give
you a free queen even if they're being
funny let's play yes yes so so yes so so
sometimes when you're playing and you
know you have a low rating but you're
playing somebody tough right art with a
tough rating sometimes that's why don't
get intimidated sometimes they might
either joke around or just play down to
your left you know so so obviously
Bishop c4 but now that he knew wow I'm
playing a guy that's not so good maybe I
can do some funny stuff all right well
let's let's see and remember Danny is
not the comedian of the group so so
let's see maybe he'll get a penalized
for being so so bad here so now
obviously we got a big rook check here
so how should white deal with the rook
Chuck he could just play cleanup and
trade the Queen for the rook to play
like Danny he could get the knight
involved or he could simply play his
King to f1 right cause it's gonna be
tough for him the castle anyway but he
gets his knight involved all right so
Bishop attacks the night it's probably
defend us huh what's the one move White
has here to save to hold everything
together well if you play Knight to d4
it's very very tough to be a defender
when you're like in the neutral zone in
the battleground right because you can
get attacked and easily right right c5
right so where what's a way easier way
to be like the protector right like like
be like a sniper be like way up there
just protecting everybody from back
right it's not cool to retreat right and
it's not cool to retreat but but you
know if you're all material and all you
need to do is hold it together there you
go
all right so and then oh yeah that
computer things that's so good but he
played your move without the night just
efore so it's like okay three knight
again this time you can't resist it all
right so now the bishop is attacking the
rook attacking the knight it's all
falling apart so Queen to d3 Bishop
takes Queen takes the ante throws him
the big bishop check but can can white
block with c3 in this position
well he could if you wanted to but but
he's like I'm not tonight not tonight
so Bishop the d2 now Dani smart here if
he plays Bishop takes check now right
white almost has to take back with the
King right and they'll know but he takes
this first King takes and Bishop takes
so it's
check so he's not forced to take it here
he could like up play my rook so but but
he's like okay I know my king can
capture a unprotected piece of so so he
figured that out so that was good
so Dan is like its mop up time now I'm
taking your pawn I'm gonna put well I'm
actually not gonna protect my pawn
he's playing a trick here so what would
play hopefully the computer won't like
shout it out right away
yeah Knight e4 check all right so now up
three stopping the check very
interesting so as I go Cal protect so
Knight moves rook takes the open file
here
Night Moves rook attacks the night but
it's defended so the Knight attacks the
rook rook just goes back so you see see
how you guys got to get plans somehow
someway just get some plans here like a
better plan would be like like Mario
with the f4 f5 maneuver that did nothing
this guy with the rook down here okay
Brooke back just wasting moves like like
maybe you want to try like rook III here
even if it loses a pawn and then double
the rooks right and that try to get a
checks and think have fun right not just
moving your rook back and forth for
nothing and you lost the pawn anyway
where he goes back okay so obviously Oh
D and E and it's time to stop messing
around sometimes like it takes the pawn
Oh
he just can't can't resist giving this
rook away and Shaq he's in Chuck and he
can't he can't take it anymore
so that's that's it that's the
Scandinavian unless you're playing Gary
Kasparov you know it works right
just remember to give them a big check
on e5 naughty six the losing move all
right well thank you very much for
coming to another edition of beginner
breakdown